distribution de masques à l'entrée de
cette station de métro de la capitale
catalane
depuis ce lundi le port du masque dans
les transports en commun est obligatoire
près de six millions de masques ont déjà
été distribués par la police et la garde
civile dans les principales stations de
métro et arrêts de bus du pays
cela me faisait peur de prendre le métro
car il y a des gens qui ne mettait pas
de masque ni de gants en plus du fait de
mon âge et de mes problèmes
respiratoires j'ai encore plus peur
je pense que le masque devrait être
obligatoire partout pendant les
premières phases du déconfinement dans
d'autres pays les gens le font déjà
quand ils ont la grippe ou un rhume
ici on doit prendre l'habitude aussi et
on va être obligé de la prendre
maintenant l'espagne aborde ce que le
gouvernement a baptisé la fa0 du
déconfinement de nouvelles mesures
rentrent désormais en vigueur comme la
levée de rideau pour les salons de
coiffure des boutiques et d'autres
entreprises jugées non essentielles
prochain objectif pour l'espagne pour
suivre le déconfinement tout en
consolidant la baisse de la coupe
d'infection dans le pays